welcome to podcast Ville the Church of
what's happened now is brought to you by
Fuji sports calm go to Fuji for your G's
rash guards whatever the hell you have a
man needs are the mats listen I'm a fat
[ __ ] and a six I'm down with a five but
you could tug on that Saporito [ __ ] G
all day long and nothing [ __ ] happens
you can just get the plain [ __ ]
purple one and I guarantee it it's
better than he gave more before if
you're in the [ __ ] gay business go to
Fuji Sports calm right now and check in
church on your way out and get 10% off
that's how we're rolling here tonight we
take that [ __ ] meal that's a little
startup music on a Wednesday you might
be feeling a little cool sequence on my
man Kevin Brennan Z in the [ __ ] house
represent look at you looking good shame
to myself why what's the problem all
right I don't parties who gives a [ __ ]
last time I got high I thought I was
gonna [ __ ] overdose that's fine I'm
doing some pot - yeah it's impossible
right a couple things
overdose some pot I've done closed a
couple times but close I guess I got
[ __ ] so paranoid I'm like I I'm not
I'm never doing it again we've got a
couple people overdose and just kind of
leave the podcast he just walked out
just walked out Wow cuz he was he was he
couldn't he was gone yeah he was gone
of Twitter they did yeah yeah but he did
that on purpose I don't know what
happened - no I was on purpose he was
[ __ ] using every word that you're not
supposed so he kicked them off Twitter
ya know but it's genius cuz he got
kicked off Twitter and now he set up a
patreon to support
First Amendment rights and his patrons
[ __ ] doing great so I think he I think
it was like all it like a scam get
kicked off Twitter you look like a
[ __ ] hero right everybody always has
a [ __ ] side angle I I got kicked off
Twitter for a week and I felt like
something like yeah I'm like a real dude
now
I'm out Twitter for different reasons I
got kicked off to it twice and I think
checked off Facebook one time for like
the week I got shut down I can read but
I couldn't boast yeah yeah you guys sit
there and then people are tweeting about
you and just gotta sit there and [ __ ]
take it like who gives a [ __ ] when we
how to do with my life I'm worried about
whoa no but then you couldn't even like
one even like people's comments they
every time I click like on Twitter
they'd be like they remind me that I'd
like six more days in [ __ ] jail they
would tell you I was like goddamn it
then you click again you're like you
[ __ ] then you then you realize
you like it you need it and then you're
like you don't want maybe they'd
forgotten let's go and then you hit it
that's like three days and twenty-two
minutes
I know [ __ ] that and then they hold you
to it that first tweet when your things
suspensions up that's a sweet one I had
a picture of my balls up yeah seven
eight months on Twitter and then
somebody finally reported yeah I got in
Twitter beef with somebody you rather be
right yeah that's what happened I call
some guy a [ __ ] and I guess you can't I
thought you could call a guy I can't no
I know you can call you can't call women
cons cuz that's disrespectful but I
called somebody a [ __ ] on Twitter and
there and they put me on probation nine
months later they hit me up on that [ __ ]
really yeah
that was one of the words they did man
before I one was using n-word like
random F word [ __ ] I know yeah I know
what you guys say here but you say
[ __ ] listen I'm sick and tired I know
our word and the F word and the [ __ ] I
ain't got time for these now I know I
know I don't want you to talk how you
would talk behind your walls this is
what a but people come on the [ __ ]
podcast and Austin they want to be like
this [ __ ] I want you to be people
want to be smart I don't want to be
smart on a part I want you to be you
that's not warm I don't give a [ __ ] if
you got something to say I'll say it who
gives a [ __ ] if it comes back to bite us
in the ass and I come right in here what
do you think about like professional
athletes who have side accounts so they
can go comment so Kevin Durant got
caught this year so if you said
something bad about Kevin Durant he had
it's a different account they would come
and intact
it was just him hmm you should come up
with a side account I don't even have
time to account say yeah but that's a
[ __ ] move on Kevin Durant's part isn't
it to have a side account I guess I
don't know everybody they can figure out
who it is anyway what it's like I have
this side account and then he was like I
know but then he said well I didn't know
I didn't know that was me
oh I thought it was my assistant
somebody hacked me in some yes someone
hacked me it's all it's all a [ __ ]
crock of [ __ ] I got enough time for
Twitter and Facebook Instagram a friend
of mine does it for me I email them the
pictures Twitter goes crazy every time
you tweet it goes funny yeah no no we go
nuts on Twitter we got them under
control this savage isn't there ready to
fight people you got on Twitter a
million no idea but they're [ __ ] all
good people everyone I gotta have three
three thousand four thousand ex-felons
ready to do it really oh yeah they send
me pictures like a bargain arsenal it's
[ __ ] crazy ready to attack I got him
on every state you got guns you got guns
here and me I got a couple but you need
a gun right what do you mean you need to
go no you need a gun you put to protect
your property right no you're gonna
protect your property yeah but someone
get to school beast now there yeah I
think in the next year you got it listen
my daughter is five you have children
yeah it's gotta be your biggest fear
today absolutely you're in your writers
room you your friends talking also and
you get a [ __ ] text that you drag
goals and lock that right what are you
thinking right now right what you gotta
get I almost got in trouble already
because it I said where's the security
here yeah no no you got a so easy you
have to get together with eight dad and
go listen you said seven sacks of [ __ ]
you're all clean you're all stockbrokers
you're all [ __ ] [ __ ] it's time we got
a gun we take shifts at that [ __ ]
school well seriously yeah this is what
I think it's about what if she's a [ __ ]
is at all brothers you just stand at the
door
no just sitting your [ __ ] car with
coffee guy relisha well the guy comes in
the train every day alternate dad come
all guys to the clean give me a Vietnam
vet that's dying to shoot somebody
that's a guy one
brown-eyed the school yeah and blast a
kid in the head with a [ __ ] bazooka
you think I'm [ __ ] with you I'll go
to Boulder and find my old friends Fred
from Vietnam think I'll Agent Orange
they don't give a [ __ ] about anything
I really don't write you know what do
you do as a dad what are you supposed to
do sit and wait I told me get a cop
there unless you unless you go now all
private schools these people charge you
30 grand a year they better come up with
[ __ ] skilled egos all right so
where's the [ __ ] cop I go see if
there's a [ __ ] if a shooting happens
there's 50 cops here so where did it
work we don't need 50 get one here we
just in they go we can't do that I go
why can't you there are other on patrol
I go patrol them what what happens at
8:30 in the morning on a [ __ ] school
day even the blacks take that time off
they wake up late the blacks
my wife's Hispanic so I can do black
jokes I'm just worried about my buddy
over here like them with them with the
virus [ __ ] golf drops and then
[ __ ] then the [ __ ] no I'm worried
I'm worried I'm worried about the
[ __ ] scaring the kids and the
shootings no you have to as a concerned
parent as a [ __ ] uncle whatever you
gotta [ __ ] is going on in these schools
all right then
and something's gonna happen like that
so you actually something will happen
like that that a [ __ ] kid makes a
threat it's cool the dad finds out about
the dad goes down there with a
submachine gun and just blow some kid's
head off and what are you gonna do are
you gonna justify it's gonna happen
eventually you know 20 years ago we
didn't think something like Vegas would
happen we never in our dreams thought
that you could go to a concert and
showers Vegas so my brother anything is
possible today's [ __ ] world and you
have to prepare for [ __ ] anything
nothing they come at me anymore is like
wow what a [ __ ] surprise
Emily I don't even like big crowds no
that's why I like Mike my shows I don't
draw a crowd I saw maybe 30 ticket
that's all you need it started people to
get the party started
who's that if you take your dick out
only seven get offended you're in the
[ __ ] winning percentage you can't go
to jail you follow me but it's true it's
[ __ ] true
it's gonna happen somewhere yeah well I
gotta win the dad's gonna get a wind
he's gonna go you know what I'm not
gonna call my house
but daddy please he's gonna pick up that
couch under that [ __ ] couch as a
shotgun and Uzi and the leftover [ __ ]
bazooka from his Nazi days and he said
go down that school and wait for that
[ __ ] kid watch it's gonna happen he's
gonna shoot a kid that bullied his kid
no no no some one of these kids is gonna
go home and go look did you see the
YouTube shooter yeah no I did you see
the videos of the YouTube yeah let me
tell you something if I were to saw that
video I would call the feds
you knew she's about to shoot somebody
yeah look at the [ __ ] videos yeah no
she's [ __ ] about to shoot somebody
don't take a genius you could tell that
that [ __ ] was crazy
yeah but everyone's crazy right you
can't tell after they've told after the
fact so who's crazy you know I mean you
can't say oh that's person's crazy
there's not enough evidence at least
they found her that morning they found
her sleeping in her car yeah they did a
check and they called the family and
they go okay I guess she's okay
they should have checked Facebook
[Music]
testimonials pretty soon they're gonna
NCIC you like you know they should this
record and your Facebook and I'll be
[ __ ] interested right if your social
media comes up they have a score for you
four same like crazy [ __ ] or something
yeah that's got to come next I don't
give a [ __ ] I don't know I just all my
kids martyred and it's it's scary
because as you would think it's gonna be
in the worst neighborhoods at the school
I went to my senior year this guy
someone stabbed another kid and it like
a lot of these school shootings are
happening at like nice places so that
you think you're gonna move to a place
and put your kids in a good a good
situation it really you're not really
safe anywhere now yeah I live in Jersey
City so maybe I should even say that but
nah Jersey City represent and I love it
but people you know people say it's not
gonna happen here but you don't know
where it's gonna happen
just a couple of years we I was I was
out of Journal Square look it's better
it's still dumpy but it's bad a movie
theater still there yeah really yeah but
I think now they made it like a like a
church like a like a more like a not a
Mormon but like Jehovah Witness kind of
a church cuz I see a lot of people
dressed up standing in front of it
that place used to be scary it must have
been nice growing up there right just
[ __ ] no no rules I used to go to the
movies there and there was a sporting
good on that Street when you went
running Journal Square
so the buses come this way from North
Bergen this way and right there we're
going like south I guess all you would
say they used to be a street in fact the
guy that blew up the World Trade Center
his office is right on that he had an
obelisk
it had an office on the first time yeah
that's where they're off in 1991 or
whatever yeah 91 93 whatever it was
there across the street from there when
I was a kid that was the best warning
that even though North Bergen had levees
and had two floors that one had the best
[ __ ] in the world and that we would take
a bus go up Sporting Goods and go to
that movie theater I went to see all
those Pink Panther movies there down to
the gills on a Saturday you know six of
us were not supposed to smoke weed we
buy a nickel bag get seven joints and go
to the movies there I saw Richard Pryor
live on the Sunset Strip there yeah yeah
I must have seen 20 movies near it was
always an adventure
yeah there's you gotta take a bus out
there where do you smoke on that before
you got after you got off the bus I
threw out the bus sometimes before on
the way up the hill of the way about
four hours during we would smoke he's
smoking at theater ever
none knows in new york city theaters
I've sparked up yeah in the eighties you
could spark up at a movie theater in New
York you could spark up and on 42nd
Street and maybe an usher would say
something yeah that's her up there but
there was a movie theater on 181st
Street that two movies for two dollars
yeah you could light a crack pipe and
nobody would say a [ __ ] word and then
I smoked crack in there wouldn't is not
a joke I saw officers and gentlemen
their smoked crack crack ice melted
there how he's melted I don't like this
was like when people put in Coke in his
cigarettes at that point 85 yeah I was
as a matter of fact I wasn't doing coke
then I was just smoking pot and I
remember smelling in the movie theater
going who the [ __ ] which smoked [ __ ]
this [ __ ] to come ceiling goes I can
come food oh I know exactly what movie
was the one with the black dude that he
owned the pizza place and they knew kung
fu and I know my god I was gonna say do
the right thing no no it's similar it's
before do the right thing and it's Leroy
Bruce Leroy yeah yes he improves Leroy
comes up there they the guy just died
the guy that played the karate expert in
the movie just passed maybe two years
ago and they had poster bottom up the
Shogun of Harlem
hurry up that was his name I'm a Shogun
of Harlem
yeah my wife said she used to go to all
these [ __ ] movies no would you
everything she grew up in the Bronx but
she said they used to just they she grew
up loving kung fu because you watch all
these kung fu movies how you get there
were only four channels in you and one
of them was just kung fu where'd you
grow up Boston I know I grew up
Philadelphia okay how'd you end up in
New York Tommy yeah I mean I went I
didn't start everybody start in Chicago
know what I used to talk to Pete all the
time our first mutual friend that's when
you were ready you had a deal with ABC
you would develop on this show eh yeah
Eastern before 2005 and then I didn't
see you anymore and I know I disappear
where'd you go you can't
me I couldn't maintain it I never
podcast then it's it's [ __ ] looking
back it's very frustrating to watch
these [ __ ] guys
nothing I'm bitter but I am a little bit
but watch these guys they get something
and they can they can kind of keep it
going with a podcast you know so I had a
lot of fans but then they just you just
lose them because I couldn't I didn't
get another special you know I didn't
did the pilot for NBC didn't get picked
up it was just [ __ ] and then you just
sitting there like where'd everybody go
and there was no communication like
there's no Twitter there's no like
people people just you know I had a lot
of fans them but they just [ __ ] drift
away you know and it's it's annoying
there was like that with Twitter I could
have kept them you know because they
just people even say now oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
I listen to your podcast I remember your
podcast
nobody's perfect but they say they say
oh yeah I was a fan when you did your
HBO thing and it was I didn't ever I
didn't either I didn't know about my
podcast so it's it's [ __ ] up that like
all this [ __ ] we're like you could just
build your base awful Twitter and and
you know dude just you can kind of stay
in touch with your friends you couldn't
back then I did an HBO a half hour and
then it's [ __ ] done you know I mean
some of it's my fault because I'm not
that good you know but can I did it with
Bill burr he's doing pretty good he's
[ __ ] parlayed it in something louis
c.k he was one of the [ __ ] Patrice
O'Neal he's dead but it's a soul yeah
but I'm just saying like oh but but some
guys [ __ ] Norton you know some guys
but but you know it's hard show business
is not [ __ ] uh it's not easy you know
listen to 2009 I was ready a drop out
like for Ray on the road yeah and maybe
do stand-up and yeah you like doing
stand-up right I like doing stand-up but
when you have a family it's different
yeah right you know what you love doing
stand-up when you're single you're I
[ __ ] deal
well you can't enjoy as much because
then my wife's like how's that on the
road I have to say it sucks and then it
kind of does suck because I know she's
[ __ ] mad that I'm not there you know
well when you're married and you have
kids you gotta come on you know can you
imagine this was 20 years ago we were
working Tuesday through Sunday yeah you
came home on Monday
- laundry pay your bills deposit your
check down here again - is not the
morning right and Wednesday you did
radio Thursday yeah you know in Friday
you did radio thought that was work jack
now we do Thursday Friday salary and
that's too much like that's too much I
can do that twice a month and put my
whole heart into it and do two shows to
the solid I can't do two weeks in a row
no more NLA three four week in a row
[ __ ] internet no more that ship
sailed
I could do the every other week for a
while and that's what you tell your
agent every other week yeah oh yeah you
could do every week right I throw the
dates if I wanted to but I don't want to
yeah it's too exhausting have a family
you're exhausted then you feel like
you're gonna [ __ ] die yes I can't do
attention to this Yeah right dude that
would end up I can't give the process I
did that four years ago and we lost we
went down the tubes I wanted an eight
week run you can't do it oh you people
just dropped out of the show another
broadcast doesn't remember that a
podcast is like a [ __ ] a wave that's
like a people come and people go yeah
okay I'd see the hum and people go and
then that you have two bad podcasts they
disappear and then they come back down
they had a degree and it's phrase see
something online and you make them laugh
and they come back and you have to
accept that as a human being right right
I don't look at my numbers anymore cuz I
don't want to get depressed no a new
flavor is is always on the horizon and
there's nothing you can do that's why
you gotta respect the guys like burr and
Sebastian and and we'll keep pounding it
with the little Mexican get you don't
affect you oh yeah fluffy yeah you know
fluffy one stone yeah goes I don't know
how long this wind doesn't want so I got
to attack it yeah as in ten years nobody
remember fluffy there's a new fat
Mexican camp and you're out there at the
[ __ ] [ __ ] chef holger Hills casino
and flags flags I'm we're hoping I got
half a room for hopeful you know get
thirty people come
remember your podcast back in there we
remember your podcast yeah the nightly 8
to 20 edibles yeah no it's [ __ ] up cuz
I always think I'm the same age you know
and I see fans ago oh we saw you you
know ten years ago and then I'm like how
they look old I guess I look old too but
but when you do comedy you just you kind
of lose track of that so so I guess you
do gotta push it when it's hot but you
know back to your point about like might
like whenever someone there's like some
scandalous something happens with my
podcast the numbers [ __ ] go crazy and
then as soon as it stops they go away
you know and then and then you know I
get into fights on my podcast some
people like you know my wife's like what
the [ __ ] you're doing it go that's what
you know I'm not doing it because people
liked it but they do like it you know
what I mean it and and I don't mind cuz
I don't mind [ __ ] getting in
arguments with people you know I just
you know like I was on I was got in a
fight with [ __ ] on Norton Show on a
serious show cuz some guys some guy
funky and said something about my
daughter you know we I said yes I said
his wife was fat you know I said you're
valuing I said your what you're fat your
wife's probably fair you're from the
Midwest and heat then he says how about
my daughter so I [ __ ] grab them you
know and then nor it's like you can't
[ __ ] touch people and on radio but
I'm like I knew the [ __ ] numbers
would go crazy you know I mean like I
didn't do it for that reason but when
you go in there you just try to have a
[ __ ] regular conversation like honey
I barely even want to [ __ ] do it
myself you know what I mean like when I
do a podcast and I and it's just you
know and like I did one last night I
forget the name of what I'm like I just
wanted to [ __ ] leave you know it's
just a [ __ ] regular like I don't have
a [ __ ] regular conversation I know
the fans can get that anywhere right
they can listen if I can talk radio
unfuckin yeah no I agree on 1010 wins
over the [ __ ] station I just don't
want this to be [ __ ] poison backstage
MTV Awards 91 my god what your show yeah
yeah no yeah but you're already you're
already like a guy you're like a guy you
know like I'm I'm a regular white guy so
I don't have a regular white guy show
[ __ ] that you know I mean I want to be I
want to be a regular guy no I don't want
to be a regular guy I want it to be a
fun one to be outrageous you know I mean
so so that's what I tried if I can do I
try to push [ __ ] buttons and I try it
but every time I get into like a
situation the
it's [ __ ] spiked so now I stopped
listening today I stopped watching
numbers because I don't be a [ __ ]
[ __ ] to the numbers you know I mean so
I don't even want to know I'm just like
I just try to have a [ __ ] good time
and now I sound like I need it have a
good time no but I try to like I try to
make it fun for me if it's fun for me
it's probably fun for the fans you know
how many podcast do you do a week I do
I've won it Kumi is Network you know cou
Mia from ona and that's like behind a
paywall and then I have another that's
called Bob burning bridges and then I
have my own ship my at my other show but
called misery loves company and I do
that that's that's you know that's no
there's no pay while there but you know
and even doing two shows a week it's it
gets a little [ __ ] you know I mean
could I do a [ __ ] show four days a
week I don't know I mean I admire like
Brogan he does it he does four hours
twenty [ __ ] two shows a week oh he
does yeah it's amazing and even
Bilborough is tim i go how do you just
sit there and talk to yourself I
couldn't [ __ ] talk to myself like I
think it's like amazing you can [ __ ]
or either he's crazy you just sit there
and talk to yourself I got do you pause
it when you run hey cuz I just keep
talking I'm like I can't even imagine so
even doing two shows a week is a little
bit of a is a little bit of a challenge
you know how many spots do you do a week
still the city I don't you know I'm
gonna do more my wife was like going to
school and cuz she's bilingual she was
going to bilingual school so I'm my
nights were a little bit [ __ ] block but
now I want to do more spots cuz III just
it's more I don't know it's been more
fun lately I've new material my podcasts
are going good so I wanna like get out
there I want to be like I want to have
like a [ __ ] late I wanna have like a
late and late in my career Renaissance
you know I mean because it's it's hot
not most many people do it you know I
mean so I think it'd be cool if I could
[ __ ] have like be like an old guy and
be like keep up with the [ __ ] young
guys you know I mean like I work at
economy selling and somebody comes up
and one of young guys or a young guy
kills and I follow him like yeah [ __ ]
you [ __ ] like I'm not afraid of
you let's do this right
cuz I'm supposed to be like in my my in
my later years I'm supposed to be like
just [ __ ] feeling sorry for myself
and being like what was me but my son's
five I don't have time for that [ __ ]
how old do you know I'm older than you I
looked up my look
I am I looked up on your Wikipedia 63
yeah I'm older than you right you look
great I do
you're like a 42 with some [ __ ] yeah I
mean it you know my mom looks my mom's
like 80 my mom listen up looks good I
wouldn't [ __ ] her but you know I mean
she still looks good so but so we hold
up you know but but I'm saying I said
I'm still old you know my brothers three
olds older than me need a heart attack
so you don't know it doesn't you know
any heat exercise whatever so you don't
know so I'm saying like I want to have
like a [ __ ] as you oh and that's what
I like this putt yeah he's fine but I
just want to have to that was like a
vegan now and you know whatever but I'm
saying I wanna have like I want to have
like a [ __ ] late in career and
microwatt to be I gotta be one of those
guys be like I'm not afraid I'm not
afraid of you what you following you
young [ __ ] you know I mean I
don't give a [ __ ] you know cuz I always
thought like when you watch these guys I
mean partly it's like my brother Neal's
in the business so I'm like I'm kind of
like competitive with him in a way and
so I'm like [ __ ] is so I think you
need that you need somebody if I can
keep you like competitive you know what
I mean but you're doing great so I don't
know I'm [ __ ] talking to you about it
I'm an old man I know but that's what
I'm saying you're like a role model for
me you're like a [ __ ] it was
hilarious because I was already gone a
different direction when I was getting
movies and [ __ ] yeah I know what the
stand-up is just not getting it and
that's fine what do you mean not not
getting it for you
I wasn't clicking the stand-up just was
but it is now uh yeah a little more yeah
a little more
it wasn't clicking back that in 2009 I
started clicking in about 2000
ten was when I started putting it
together that's the sad [ __ ]
situation that way you're saying forever
and then it just you just got good at
you just we're in 2010 you're like I'm
clicking now doubt it took me 19 years
to find my rhythm okay
the rhythm I feel like I'm finding my
rhythm now cuz I'm too long too [ __ ]
long but I feel like now I'm like I'm
matter I have reasons to be mad and I'm
[ __ ] like I've kids I got a [ __ ]
support them so I'm like I don't give a
[ __ ] you know I mean like I'm like let's
let's just [ __ ] do this you know I'm
not as nervous as much I'm like let's
[ __ ] do it and play a little attack I
just I'm like just be as aggressive as I
can you know I mean out for a white dude
with a web page yeah like a website yeah
no I don't do that I got to do more of
that but I have people helping me this
podcast is like been good because people
come out like you got the [ __ ] guy
for the AIDS you know I mean but people
come up and they and they want to help
you you know I mean guys who can like
technical I don't know I don't know how
to do this you gotta get a work page
yeah videos you gotta get a YouTube page
right web or YouTube but they gotta be
able to go somewhere right okay go for
this certain step step
yeah but I got I gotta go for I got I
don't have enough I don't have enough
money of course you can system like no
I'm gonna turn right down saying for my
kids I got a [ __ ] I know so this is
how you make money yeah i mean i
remember louis c.k was like he's like
yeah i got a man I only have so many
years to make money he was right cuz he
got [ __ ] busted you know I mean but
I'm saying like you only have so many
years I can't I can't sit around my kids
really God daddy again he ran out of
jokes you still write a lot I try to I
don't write as much as I used to but
writing scripts or anything like now
never I think they're always I don't
even like the [ __ ] I don't like that
unlike the format I don't even like the
[ __ ] type I don't like they look
what's the format you have to [ __ ] do
screenplays in like that thing where you
have to like although you say like yeah
the ladies fry up yeah you like they
have to like - parentheses and [ __ ] I
don't do any parentheses I've write in
my book I have a notebook I write in the
in the notebook but but I don't want I
don't like sure I don't like show
business either that's why I don't like
I another resign I don't like LA because
a lot of [ __ ] rules there's so many
rules out here you know you only meeting
with while you were here no no no I
didn't get on stage at all cuz I was
kind of a vacation Messiah I know I know
how to do stand-up you know I mean
somebody gets me you want to do a show
on Van Nuys ago no I don't know I don't
want to van [ __ ] Nuys where are we
now North Hollywood yeah it's even
farther than that right nobody is closer
yeah that's why I'm saying it's for its
18 minutes and then I told a guy I
couldn't do it and cuz I said I couldn't
do it he wanted me even more in that
typical you tell somebody was a failure
no I'm saying no in show business if you
tell somebody you're not interested
they're like only must be good you have
to act like you don't want to [ __ ] do
it right got a point
oh it's like if he's if they say we
couldn't you do it for this much money
go now
even if you even if there's not a money
reason if you go now then like they
offer you more money so whatever so
that's it but the anyway I don't want I
do I don't like the ones the vacation
yeah and I don't like doing stand-up
like I hate this guy still in a this
guy's from New York huh and I gonna be
like hey I'm from New York you want
pizza you know I mean I don't know
[ __ ] be like that I don't you know
what I mean so now we just go out put
two everybody go ahead Neil Brendan's
brother cuz Neil lives out here and he's
big he's like people think he's like
very successful so I just like mock that
I'm like hey I'm Neal Brennan's brother
even though I'm [ __ ] older than him
oh if I can beat the [ __ ] out of him
Esther said you said you didn't he that
you thought he didn't like you or
something
yeah you don't say much to me I always
said hello Lee where are you saying The
Comedy Store he's probably afraid to you
know he's a sweetheart of a guy just now
he's not [ __ ] so he's a [ __ ]
gold-digging start [ __ ] show business
type was that good know what he's doing
you know no he's he's probably that's
what he's probably afraid of you cuz
you're like a real dude and you can
probably sniff it out No
I shake his hand he's alright he's a
good guy he doesn't bother nobody he
just explained he doesn't I know he said
he knows how to work it yeah he works
and he writes he's a great writer I've
complement to them yeah I told him a few
times if I could write like you I'd be a
[ __ ] murderer what are you do you
write your jokes you just not like him
I'll tell you that much you taste a
[ __ ] joke that guy but you right you
just go up with with something in your
head
yell a story sometimes you have
something in your head sometimes you
tell a joke but to sell the joke maybe
you tell a story you gonna whip the
[ __ ] joke it's different styles you
know it's it's I used to just be
machine-gun like Rodney
yeah it's one-liners that's funny for 18
minutes when you got 45 minutes
ain't that [ __ ] it's [ __ ] up people
don't understand that
so liner yeah I work for Steven Wright
one time and people just got sick of his
[ __ ] act after a while but 18 minutes
you yeah the one line wasn't one line
yeah be they look at their phone yeah
that goes your one yeah once they get
the rhythm once they get the rhythm
you're done if you tell them the story
justify why you're saying these thoughts
tell them something that happened in
your life it's easy to tell them the
jokes at the time guys are if you
believe in something and you bring it to
the stage even if it sounds wrong but
you sell it the right way you're a
[ __ ] genius you love me you better
look at a comedy club watching the
comics before you and some guy that's
not edgy tries to be edgy and a backfire
zone yeah it's not edgy right why is he
gonna guys like you and I will say
whatever whatever the [ __ ] is necessary
you have a point and we'll deal with the
complications later right that's that's
the good part about doing stand-up
though oh that was the part that if it
was up to me I'd go [ __ ] nuts stage
and I do go nuts on stage tour degree i
tame it down a little bit because I just
tame it down because it doesn't
necessarily have to go there you
yeah but also you can't you can't do
what you want to do cuz you got if you
followed the guy you're on a show you
know if you go on to the comedy store
you want your one guy in the show so
unless you're gonna go up like Kinnison
screaming with the [ __ ] jacket and
then like the whole thing but that's a
lot that's a lot of work to go up there
every night doing how many school is a
tough place to go up every no that's
what I'm saying so just follow the lead
your brother Rogen yeah white Chappelle
yeah you don't [ __ ] know Ali Wong
it's right combination of [ __ ]
killers right and there you are at
quarter to 11:00 they've already seen
three killers right you better go up
there and bring something Oh an arrow
right a [ __ ] drums you better bring
something beige right so your energy
know when you go to the stove well I
know destroy an anxiety right mm-hmm
like 20 [ __ ] seven years economy and
I'm looking me in the eye telling you as
I sit back there and go how can I get
out of here right now when I'm nobody
knowing damn without me not pissing
people off yeah like that's the but then
when you get up you're okay right
I still does like that here boy soon as
I see that light turn blue it's post
time [ __ ] right right you can't run now
I'm just saying sometimes you what you
can't really you know if they saw
somebody if you go up who somebody who
kills right before you it's just it gets
a little you can't always do exactly
what you want to do cuz you got to deal
with what you're with the wake of what
they created you know anyone will tell
you something the whole wake is whatever
wake you creating yeah and when you
follow somebody okay
think about that no I know I know it's
probably five you've been doing comedy
as long as I have you know that this
times this times I go into that [ __ ]
main room I gotta follow Chris D'Elia
and I could feel his [ __ ] coming out of
my [ __ ] cuz he's up there just kill
him clean he's likeable he's
good-looking in my mind I can't follow
that
mmm if I walk up there with that mindset
like I did for 20 years you dead yeah
you have to go to the comedy store a
warning to follow the best [ __ ]
right oh sorry go to the store yeah
I like to follow some [ __ ] magician
but that's not the case Brian you're
following Joe Rogan and you know like I
always said going to economies first
like getting in your car to go get you
nobody gets in a car to go get you like
what are you going I'm gonna go down the
sunset they gonna put a bullet in my
line I'll be back in about two days you
know nobody does this mm-hmm you gotta
be crazy to do this when you go to the
store no I like this week I'm trying to
write new material I'm not going to
[ __ ] store I'm not fighting those
savages mm-hmm I've got a flap isn't a
hind I go to the fourth wall and I not
stop at the haha and hide but you know
there's some weeks that use this you
can't lift like a heavyweight every week
right
there's so we just go and [ __ ] do a
couple push-ups with a couple sit-ups
and you do some yoga you switch it up a
little bit you know the store you sit
back there I mean you don't want to say
I'm not drinking all right I'm not drink
it so I'm gonna set the bar for mm-hmm
if I sit back that I'm watching the
girls
so I'll just sit with Ritchie shorts
it's up at the top there that last row
mm-hmm and I'll watch three or four guys
before me and I'll [ __ ] working
myself out Jagan I'll be scared as [ __ ]
as long as I could see light Klein oh
the doors open I'm all right if they
lock the door I get anxiety it's a rage
fight yeah 27 years don't come and I
still get [ __ ] it anxiety butterflies
[ __ ] something
Kichi you don't say it well it's kind of
like I just started coming to four
months ago
and it's hardly there's a part of it
that I love and there's parts that are
great but then there's also parts of it
that like make you think like why am I
putting myself through this too maybe in
20 years be one of the top 10% that's
doing like there's there has to be
something about it that keeps you in a
position if you we never discussed this
the percentage somebody broke it down to
me like maybe 15 years ago to calm me
stall and they
the percentage of stand-ups compared to
doctors and there's thousands comedians
got this thousands in this country you
know lucky we all Kevin Brennan to even
be in the circle that we've been you
have any [ __ ] idea like when I wake
up in the morning I used to be pissed
off I'm not pissed off anymore cuz I
proved my point which is why I wasn't a
criminal I was a stand-up comic yeah I
don't know I mean yeah no I know I mean
I know what you're saying but I I have a
problem like I can't like I don't I'm
not I'm like I'm still mad about
something
like I don't know what it is I'm mad
about something so I used that to go up
on stage like if I don't feel it I'll
just tap into that like I'll just happen
to like and that key that gets me that
gets me away from being nervous you know
I'm people go why you manic I do the
same thing sometimes I go I don't know
why I'm mad I might be mad at my wife I
might be manages life or just like the
fact that like you know like show
business you're whatever stand-up or
like I'm following a guy who's [ __ ]
killing you know and then you're like
why the [ __ ] do why is the this guy have
to be [ __ ] killing cuz I don't want
to deal with this [ __ ] tonight and then
I go up there and the [ __ ] crowds
looking at me like where's the other guy
you know and then it's what I just used
a [ __ ] but I'm still I still feel
like I'm mad I'm just [ __ ] mad and I
got at some saying I want to be like I'm
like a mad [ __ ] comic well use it to
your van I'm not when I go I still when
I go up on stage I want to be mad and
just [ __ ] even if I follow the
Pilbara whatever I'm like I don't give a
[ __ ] man you're the Captain Kirk of the
other prize baby yes so Hong coming up
my man I'm so [ __ ] you from the home
of Rocky Balboa yeah I'm saying what are
you scared yes I fight the worst that
can happen is like I get murdered you
get shot in the head yeah I'm [ __ ]
you want like a soldier yeah they'd
build a statue of funny in front of
[ __ ] the comic strip well some I get
murder Ellucian out there with statue so
I get murdered I get murdered who gives
a [ __ ] right [ __ ]
so who cares about dying in a [ __ ]
Stan I mean you're you're worried but
now I'm like I gotta [ __ ] worry about
dying you know
man you're killing in the name oh right
you're killing in the round on that city
and I'm not that funky let me give some
shoutouts here real quick here I can
tell you mad so Eddie can barrel see
dizzle
that's quad in Arizona I'm coming the
first week of May at Tempe Eric see quad
Rex Jojo menisci Julio
Cheyenne's what are you nuts
Jimmy from [ __ ] Road Arkansas there
Jimmy roads from Arkansas chase leopard
and my man Nick fat oh god oh are you
[ __ ] nuts Oh are these guys who are
these guys the people in the pictures of
the guns oh right
we got people out there the jungles
getting red on't forget Columbus next
Thursday night that's all that's left
either you show up Thursday night I'm
not gonna see you [ __ ] so now
you're [ __ ] once a twenty it's Friday
Friday well you show Thursday the people
who show real respect show up on
Thursday anyway ready to go prepared
you're waking up hi I'm [ __ ] 420 if I
was here with Lee we would have started
the marathon on Wednesday you're gonna
bet high we're gonna bet high and waking
up high beside this I'll take you to
[ __ ] Columbus and you'll be that a
Bulls for three days drink eat let [ __ ]
in the California what's that place that
has all the fun 2000 editions you don't
know that she came she came back to
Columbus funny bone right yeah you'll be
it would day every day for lunch that
must be pretty cool though I mean have
you guys been going to Columbus Ohio
like yeah like to me like that seems
like the coolest part of call me is
getting to travel the country and I know
I'm gonna cook the same mauls 20 years
in or old musket old at some point but
to me like it just sounds kind of cool
but I've never come in this club or this
city for 20 years
I never do not then I go to a city I
never do nothing well if a lot of times
I don't have a car and then I go then
they go to a club that ended they go
what you did today I got nothing I love
a [ __ ] car just sat in my [ __ ] you
don't look for a wall I go for a walk
besides but I don't like go to the zoo I
never been to a zoo
I never been everybody's like nobody
wants to go to the [ __ ] aquarium you
know I mean nobody's asking you know
birthday but B I talked to other
comments ago I went to the did they go
you want to go to the ballgame I go now
sit in a [ __ ] Sun all day I'd be a
football get your pens if I was
headlining I can't go but if I was
featuring I'd be there why cuz you'd
unless responsibility yeah you top all
day and talk [ __ ] and tell stories all
you got to do is go up into 25 minutes
and write so funny that you said about
the 19 minutes for one-liner yeah
somebody comes in and pays $25 you can't
be an astro game Oh [ __ ] dang go to a
[ __ ] that's true yeah you gotta rest
up you really can't
I used to get in there I used to get
livid when there were no waitresses were
wanna [ __ ] the the feature cuz he did
better but I'm like he that you don't
have a check spot he don't have you
don't have last call you [ __ ]
and they thought he would ne was younger
and he was like I'm like he [ __ ] dumb
[ __ ] and they wouldn't [ __ ] me cuz I
call them dumb [ __ ] no it's just fried
people don't know that side of the
business you know I mean like that you
got all this responsibility I think it's
like all fun and games but it's no it's
that's very that I funny
listen I only have one opportunity at
this in my world this is never ever
gonna happen again it's not gonna happen
again
I'm not 28 and this is gonna happen
so I'd rather you do 9 shows a month
well I'll give a hundred percent why my
bomb one of those show know what happens
when you bomb what happens when you bomb
you take the right number whatever you
just taken out but what happens what
happens with the crowd they just they're
you I they're your fans right yeah and
listen oh you didn't bomb bomb you just
don't have your good show yeah you just
don't have a good show maybe a Thursday
night yeah you rusty you know yeah yeah
but you haven't done 45 since Sunday
nights right oh that's sadly the week
before it's not like la a 45-minute film
right right so if you stay home for 10
days that's why I always do at least one
45-minute set at the Ice House in
between those two weeks yeah to stretch
that muscle or not that Thursday night's
gonna be a [ __ ] long
my friend yeah have you guys bomb like
bomb bomb like is it for me
I just started my hope but my whole
bodies aren't sweating and like they
have you do have sets like that anymore
where maybe it's not the whole set but
maybe like 20 minutes of it's just a
silent absolutely oh absolutely
I didn't think I connected with them
that well this time in Nyack as it did
the first time after the snowstorm that
Thursday night and [ __ ] I could feel it
something wasn't it wasn't clicking but
that as long as you know this as long as
you're not getting on the phone calling
your brother Neil and going dog I just
killed the guy act that yeah it probably
started right when I go back to my room
that night what do you do I have a
journal yeah and I write I hate a bag of
dicks and I write the reason and why it
happened yeah I do tell you're right you
exactly know what happened mmm-hmm lack
of energy
you took a [ __ ] chance on the joke
you took a joke in the wrong direction
you know what sometimes getting there at
5:00 in the afternoon when you have an 8
o'clock show isn't that good of an idea
my scrambled there's a thousand reasons
why I think the reason is we [ __ ] up I
was doing a show uh I guess I'm like a
year and a half ago it's right near
Christmas and uh so I thought I thought
I was getting tired you know so I get I
got some more caffeine and then because
I just thought I needed something for
the show you know so I get some more
caffeine and then I'm and then I'm
sitting there louis c.k walks in so I
got a [ __ ] so I mean that's not a big
deal but then then he goes I go when are
you gonna go on he goes I'll go on after
you so then everybody here is that Lou
East there so now everyone's Pilon did
the guy from Conan was in New York
they're all piling in this [ __ ] in
the the village underground at the
Comedy Cellar so I go up on stage
I'm like a [ __ ] mess because I got
too much caffeine and now I'm like hype
now I'm like nervous even though I
shouldn't be nervous so I go up on stage
I'm like town I'm like I'm like Mike I
got dry mouth and I'm just I'm so
disgusted with myself because I'm like
you're a [ __ ] how long you been like
every night on stage I'm like how long
doing this and I felt like I had no idea
how to like deal with it I know how to
do any any idea like what to even you
know I did some crowd work but it was
and then I got off Louie goes that was
good I get was a [ __ ] mess so it's
it's just it's it's amazing how like it
and I'm but I learned like that just
don't [ __ ] don't get to whatever like
you I learned my lesson but it was still
like it was still like so annoying to me
cuz I've been doing it too long to have
a [ __ ] show like that you know it's
one thing if I'm new when I get I got an
audition for [ __ ] Letterman and I'm
nervous but I that wasn't the case I've
been doing it too long and I just was
like thrown so I don't know if whatever
[ __ ] ends where you're just thrown
for if something will just [ __ ] get
you you know whether it's you're tired
travel you just didn't eat right you're
[ __ ] got diarrhea or something
[ __ ] variables people know that
people don't know the people don't know
and so and they think like what's wrong
with Joey today sometimes you do a show
where people laugh and they come up to
you after the show and hey well that was
a great show I've seen you two times
before and that's the best time of a
senior but you still go it was a [ __ ]
show yeah I just did a [ __ ] show
compared to what I did last week right
at this place okay now you would go back
to your room and you make your
adjustments and Friday early maybe I
pick up the energy and there it is yeah
and then the Late Show is easy now I'm
steamrolling yeah by sad but that's good
eh then I need I wouldn't stop me you
know I wouldn't think that you be you'll
be there's dedicated to the listen they
gonna pay 25 bucks for you yeah I mean
it's very you know hey [ __ ] bucks for
you even if I they don't laugh but they
know I left my heart on the edge yeah
that's how I feel now like I can't
control everything but I'll [ __ ] I'll
fight it I'll fight it I fight and I
[ __ ] yeah and I try to give them
fresh material yeah always try to give
them something fresh
you're always trying shitty but if the
bums you drain it yeah
even if it bombs you tried it yeah I can
I don't want to go see a comic and I'm
excited about do the same mount where he
did last year when I see him something
in your life
had a happy writing so I ain't gotta
happen something happened right I dare
myself sometimes I'm like don't be a
[ __ ] dude a joke like I'll have the
joke in my head I'll be like uh it's not
it's not the right time I go just do it
you [ __ ] you know what I love to
improvise at the store I could go crazy
at the store when that dude when I
walked up he plays music for me like a
run with it and I've done it a thousand
times before now I don't do it no more
and the last time I did it was about
three weeks ago I went nuts the original
and I felt good about it when I walked
on my god I still got that animal yeah I
just tame it in here from time to time
because the crowd has tightened up a
little bit original role I've got in
there some nights and I said some [ __ ]
that the church people get it yeah I
pass people get it yeah but people that
are just visiting here we're going to
the store to see Chris D'Elia yeah I'm
flying with it yeah but you tried it
yeah no it is a little how many's about
it has got a little weird it's got a
little weird but you know you you got it
you could listen if you're if you're
like I'm gonna do it then I then that's
the way it is you know I mean we see
cakewalk up you know he's just I'm like
that jokes inappropriate even I'm
offended by I'm like at least he's
[ __ ] doing it and he's taking the
[ __ ] chance you know committing to it
committing yeah he's commanding to like
I go to open mics to watch Lee at the
fourth wall yeah and I see this eight
comics nine comics and you steal their
best jokes
no I'm kidding of course every one of
those kids will say something that is
funny but that's what I learned that
commitment is not there right so the
joke is knowing void yeah
that will keep writing woody stuff but
until they commit to that joke and I
don't know what part of it do you commit
it's when your whole soul is inside joke
if you tell if you throw a punch you
throw it like this it's not gonna fit
and paying up for you that's what it's
like approach right like this you're
covering your name in your tenant your
timid I created you afraid it'll bomb so
yeah your timid with it even strike the
best guy a commitment that I've ever
seen in the business is Doug Stanhope
yeah when he commits he commits yeah and
he commits and this people slamming
bottles and saying I'm out of here but
he committed right and I could agree
with like you falling audience member
and I'm not laughing at Stanhope but I
see a couple people get off and stuck
Doug is up there with a bottle of booze
smoking those [ __ ] cigarettes and
he's [ __ ] talking from the heart I'm
all-in with Doug Stanhope and I'm all-in
what any copy that does that right it's
when a comic is talking on a line and
they're not committed they're telling
you the joke but their shoulders are
hunched up right that's lack of
experience it's not their fault I'm not
mad at them mmm-hmm you know maybe when
you were doing comedy at the twelve
years mark you did a joke that didn't
work and some somewhere six years later
you popped up the joke and now the joke
works what do you think you got funny
and no you committed to a joke yeah you
committed to the [ __ ] joke I used to
not be committed I know people are
getting sick of this but I still might
not be committed because I didn't think
I was the best guy on the show cuz I
used to be on a lot of shows with Dave
Attell so I was like he's funnier than
me so I I shouldn't really I shouldn't
be but now I'm like [ __ ] that oh you
like to say that it doesn't matter it's
like there's always gonna be someone
funnier than me so I gotta I gotta
commit to I got a I got a [ __ ] family
like I gotta commit to this [ __ ] or just
get the [ __ ] off stage don't do it I
used to [ __ ] my pants featuring for Dave
Attell why just knowing that he was
gonna be watching you he was gonna be
watching me I'd be [ __ ] my [ __ ]
pants on stage when I'd feed ya Miami
and weird place yeah so I would you know
like I would go nuts and a couple
headliners would complain he never
complained laughing nah he don't give a
[ __ ] they follow anything those guys
they say he's a beast
they're beasts he'll fight it on he
don't matter
he never said he just you don't it don't
matter what he follows he's like I he
don't even say I don't give a [ __ ] he
just you just know he don't give a [ __ ]
from like 4/3 for like 25 years and
that's what the audience wants to know
no but that's why didn't they pay for
and that's why they look because he's
like he's you know a lot of comics they
they even if they pretend like they're
pretend edgy but they're not edgy and
the audience knows that but if you're
like legitimately like a little bit
loose upstairs like it tells a little
crazy but that's but that's what they
like I mean the jokes are great but they
also like that he's that [ __ ] thing
like stanhope like he's like Eeyore
yeah he's the [ __ ] annoying right what
and [ __ ] kills me yeah he's the thing
the real thing they commit to their
[ __ ] joke yeah what's a comic and
you'll know when you start committing
the laughter changes yeah what can you
explain I I think I know what you're
saying or I think I understand the basis
of it but wouldn't say commit what do
you do you mean like go go further into
the topic or what do you say when you
say commit if you say something out of
your mouth I don't want to hear the
words I want to hear your soul so don't
sit like for a long time comedy became
you know if this doesn't play it out for
me I'm gonna kick to free the son of an
aborted child and the audience some
people will laugh at that like they
would take it down like it was kind of
weird you're not making me laugh I'm
gonna kick a [ __ ] immortal child
commit to that [ __ ] thing that's its
experience Lee that's all this yeah but
if our aunts and it's experiencing your
writing and what you're right how can
you write about kids if you don't have
kids you know I say people how can I
[ __ ] do it how can a Cuban dude be
the head writer of a Jew show if I'm not
[ __ ] just only happens in this
country right that don't give [ __ ] you
the job to run blackish yeah then they
wonder why to show don't work well it
didn't feel authentic yeah it didn't
feel authentic that that's why it's the
same thing with your comedy
now I follow a lot of people nowadays
that you know cuz now everybody wants to
they do jokes about kids or they either
don't want kids or they're their nephew
and then I go right up and I go I got
kids and I just do my kids jokes and
they [ __ ] kill but them cuz I'm
basically saying like don't listen to
these [ __ ] mother these pieces of
[ __ ] that are just trying to like do the
kids jokes they don't want kids but they
wanted they want credit for the kids
jokes you know I'm like I got kids I
want the [ __ ] credit for the for the
laughs you know what I mean because it's
just it to me it's just I don't know to
me it's like when I used to watch like
Ray Romano or whatever I would just be
like I having kids you get jokes out of
it you know and then I would I don't
know that the point is that it's like I
if something's not authentic I'm like
don't talk about it you know I mean like
don't I don't talk about being black my
wife's Hispanic I talk about that but
but if you don't kids don't talk about
it you know that's and it won't work
anyway don't work anyway you know it
does because they don't know what the
[ __ ] they're talking about you'll get
them for a while but you'll never get to
that top the confidence thing is and
commitment thing is confusing because
like I can be I can like have confidence
and then not have confidence but mostly
it's like you got to keep your act fresh
is what I would say to anybody like you
got to keep it fresh whatever whatever
it takes to keep your act if it's like
improvising on stage if it's like
constantly coming up with new material
you got to challenge yourself that when
you really feel like not committed is
when you're sick of your act you know
and then you just go up there you just
do it by rote and you [ __ ] you don't
like it and the crowd don't like it
because they they sense that you don't
like it even if it's authentic material
even if it's material you really
believed in at one point but now yeah it
just where it's like [ __ ] clothes
they just you they just wear they just
wear it then and then you do too you'd
want something new what you didn't want
something new to wear and then the
fucked-up thing is the crowd even if
they're drunk and stupid they're still
pretty smart because you're the only
thing up there so they get what you're
doing or not doing you know what I mean
so when you go up there if you really
[ __ ] breathe them fire they get it
even if they don't know you they get it
but it but if you're not breathing fire
you know it's just some guy you know I
could tell now when you're a podcast
person or when somebody brought you to
the show yeah like I could tell how they
laugh right how they look at me yeah I
could tell that they were brought to the
show like you went to work and told your
friend you gotta come see this guy yeah
and he never that's and they you went
Dave and they laugh they come around or
at the beginning they're just [ __ ]
staring at you just don't know what I'm
from that's a phenomenal feeling like
well he's open for road I hope for road
of the week seven years yeah it was
always a dice throw why
well I bombed I bugged but he probably
loved it when you bombed right right he
set him up even better better but when I
was off then he I went off yeah but it
was always a fifty-fifty [ __ ] shot
yeah because I wasn't prepared you know
I didn't really give a [ __ ] twenty
minutes I could be twenty minutes on my
head yeah and then when I got it I'm
like I'm sick and tired of doing 50/50
[ __ ] right right I gotta take these
[ __ ] to the who play named Isaiah now
there's some about 18 minutes they eat
this is the [ __ ] room we had over one
fire in 80 minutes and I said that was
my goal even at The Comedy Store my goal
is to light that room on fire for 18
[ __ ] minutes the best is when like
that why am I always favorite shell when
I start out was the night it the night
after I bombed cuz when I bombed I would
get so I was so disgusted oh I love I
was so disgusted til next set and I was
like and then I would go up and I was so
[ __ ] pissed and I'd always have like
a good show and I always thought like
well I wish I could bomb every night cuz
the next night I always [ __ ] I have a
great show so so that's I still I still
like that feeling where I just had a
[ __ ] day and I go up on stage and I'm
like I just want to [ __ ] like I don't
give a [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] who
laughs I don't give a [ __ ] who's in the
audience you know I just want to I just
want to like [ __ ] tear it up you know
and I know it sound like yeah you know
whatever I know it sounds like an idiot
like I've been doing it this long but I
still like that feeling of like leg
let's grab the mic
and let's [ __ ] do this you know so
you got an economy selling a lot yeah I
got a lot yeah yeah so an a you know the
axe used to be stronger there but
they're not as strong as they used to be
but a lot of people you know they when I
it was like Aziz and [ __ ] Amy Schumer
and it was a lot of [ __ ] Louie they
were all coming through and but now it's
not it's not as a and I'd rather follow
somebody really good you know then then
just like just I don't know like I'd
rather somebody who [ __ ] challenges
the room and challenges the the whole
thing I just I don't like I'm like you
I'm like I like a guy was like I don't
like anything that's like [ __ ] cutesy
I don't almost I don't I don't like any
guys that appealed of women like I don't
like a guy was like if if women like
this guy a lot like I I just I don't
like that cuz I just think it's like
he's doing something wrong even though
that's not even though that's not even a
right mentality that's that's my [ __ ]
that's what I like I like somebody where
the woman's like this guy's kind of a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know or this this is
inappropriate but if a guy if a guy
really has appeal for women I'm not
impressed
anyway is it hard to get people to shows
like harder now
because I have no neck stuff because I
do smaller shows in LA and sometimes
it's because they have the store they
have all the three main clubs and then
they have the Icehouse and flappers in
New York there's tons of places to see
comedy so is it to when you have all
those amazing crowds is it harder to get
people to show up to specific places the
cellar is always crowded the sellers
probably like the Comedy Store right the
kind of stores always crowded so the
sellers always crowded the people of
high expectations and then you know so
you gotta you kind of have to live up to
them which is which is the frustrating
thing is because you can't really [ __ ]
around too much because they want it
ones like the store yeah they want it
they want you to deliver you know they
came with high expectations they don't
so that's why I like I say like we're
saying you got to challenge yourself to
like I'm gonna do this no joke I don't
give a [ __ ] it might be an appropriate
it might bomb but I'm gonna [ __ ] do
it you know cuz the number one the worst
thing you can do in an E and an E with
any of this show business thing is just
is to be afraid you know it's just the
worst and that's why I don't like it out
here because I'm always
afraid oh I'm like who's gonna who's
this guy like when I came in today I
didn't even know I thought he might be I
don't know who he is you know I may I
might [ __ ] rub him the wrong way
maybe he's a [ __ ] big deal you know I
mean like I go to the commies Esther
coos I come to the commie stores their
anniversary I'm like I don't want to
[ __ ] in and I want to I'll go up on
stage but I want to [ __ ] mingle cuz
it's like cuz he I don't know who I'm
talking to uh this guy was where I was
talking to a guy at the [ __ ] he goes
alright book the this in New York he
goes I booked the I was just talkin
regular to him you know and then he goes
oh I met you two in Aspen and I go oh I
go what you know he turns out he's
booked and Jimmy Fallon I and all of a
sudden it's like [ __ ] didn't change you
know like I'm like oh yeah he was there
to see somebody and then I had to do my
yeah and I did my ten minutes I knew I
wasn't gonna get the show but I just I'm
like I know I'm not gonna get the show
so I just gonna had a good time but out
here I feel like everybody somebody the
guy to [ __ ] the concierge at the
[ __ ] hotel somebody you know I mean so
it's it's I'm joking but I'm just saying
like show business is like a little bit
funky out here you know I mean cuz I
don't know I don't know who's who you
know it doesn't even matter like Bert
Kreischer I did Bert Kreischer show
today and the guy's a [ __ ] he's a big
deal I he almost made me nervous going
to his [ __ ] house why cuz it's a big
deal he's a big deal you're a big deal
you know I mean I gotta [ __ ] I'm like
I'm Annie I'm just talking to colleagues
and it's like don't fool I was talking
at teamster tammy goes go in there and
[ __ ] he goes go in there and kill it
with [ __ ] Joey I'm like what I
thought we're just gonna have a [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah no I keep it so I'm just
saying it's like I feel like you know I
come out or there's a little have you
know I in like two weeks I just met the
guy where did you meet him I met him at
comeon I mean he just was sitting in one
day it was came they've they've like a
little day for like spectator seats so
he came in he was waiting to watch
Kamiya show and he watched mine I said
go watch Kevin he's funny so then I was
like yeah I was he was the only guy
there I was incorporating him into the
show and the turn and then he was
calling us a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ] us
we're doing all these dick jokes you
know because you guys talked about the
other other guys dicks a lot but you
bunch of [ __ ] and I know maybe we
[ __ ] I don't know cuz you know guys
talking about if you're if you're a
[ __ ] truck driver you know and you
bunch of men are talking about guys
dicks comics don't care they're just
joking around but he so I thought he was
funny like called us out I'm being for
being [ __ ] you know he was to get away
driver who Michaels Julie yeah tell me
on the phone
[ __ ] away I have no stories like that
to be the team's I have no stories no
get away story grow up I just that girl
I was Catholic we grew up big family we
couldn't get into trouble because my dad
would have beat the show up as he beat
the [ __ ] up isn't even for like little
things with boys six boys four girls
Jesus Christ ten kids Jesus Christ God
blesses so do you imagine every tank has
[ __ ] kids and get not staying no
could you imagine ten [ __ ] kids oh my
god now I know why you guys are [ __ ]
savage just no wonder I know we're all
we never got enough you never get when
you have ten kids you can't give your
kids what they need
well the other night that's sound like a
[ __ ] sad song but like it's like I
have two kids I feel like I [ __ ] chip
one
what do you other four brothers do ones
uh they're all kind of nobody has like a
real real job my one brother he's works
in that he works for Titleist my other
brother I used to be a pizza delivery
guy I don't know I don't know if I can
get into that but uh it's right and then
my other brother is a he like is a he's
a he's an restaurant business you know
so Neil follow me in today's Neil's the
youngest at a ten so that's why he's a
little bit again spoiled but he you know
he followed me into the stand up and I
met a lot of people at basta comedy ever
worked there in New York
well at first went to New York and only
through that the open mic then laid a
bag of dog hair jelly no that was a
rough room I mean if the audience is
where the audience's weren't good this
is a long [ __ ] this is like when Dave
Chappelle Robin Hood met in tights
yeah people I was there I was there I
might have been I'm saying there's not
even I'm saying that was a rough room it
was like a Sunday
like 1040 and it was like 11 o'clock and
there had to be maybe 30 people well
that's a lot they used to drag people in
up the street they would basically bring
them that just like an Elsa hover I get
anxiety just thinking about really how
is I can't even imagine you've been
through so much I can't even imagine a
[ __ ] stage whatever you know I mean
like I was reading your Wikipedia you've
been through a lot you know I mean like
go yeah I mean my god and uh I don't
know I mean it's it's it's it's not you
know it's not for everybody but you know
it's not like the scariest you know it's
scary but it's you know I mean bombing
sucks but but you think you wouldn't be
afraid like you know because you're all
really and all the [ __ ] you've been
through oh please that's part of the
[ __ ] no but I'm saying you people
wouldn't think you'd be a nervous to go
up on stage you know even at the
beginning even if Boston economy Club
but that was the [ __ ] all that was a
[ __ ] all I used to go to New York Comedy
Club and Dyess load that it was just a
summer of death I wanted the summer a
debt to our lives in New York for nine
months Obama but I put it together
and I went back to Colorado and the
hopes of Mike scene was [ __ ]
phenomena at the time yeah and it was
way better than New York way better you
audience yeah so you learned your lesson
you appreciate Colorado yeah Colorado
you're like 18 months a straight [ __ ]
County like a savage yeah seven nights a
week you know riding riding riding
crying bombing yeah bombing going all
the way out there to a rap a home
bombing a Mexican joint yeah Thursday
night but it was still better than New
York oh yeah cuz no matter where you
were during the week in New York it was
like going to an audience of all time
yeah and then on the weekends New York
Comedy Club you had to bring six people
here to get six minutes oh yeah so I
would tell my friends listen no they
would call me can you get his coke and I
got you
and they go why would he want us to meet
you oh my goodness at the coffee shop so
I would make them pay the $10 together
they're like what the [ __ ] is this the
deal and I give him the [ __ ] gram a
blow to grams above like [ __ ] make
him sit there or whatever you had to do
listen well I want a contest I figured
out that if the first time I won on
skill I think it was like it was like a
full-fledged six-month contest yeah
Beck's beer sponsored it it was at the
broker Joker that was the name of the
club yeah it was the backroom in the
banquet hall Wednesday night the buzz
buffet in town picked up loud the only
buffet in town yeah that shrimp
Wednesday night I mean this place was
crazy on Wednesday night it was kind of
like I would go there just to laugh
yeah just to see like old guys [ __ ]
like rich filthy old guys like my mouth
champagne for women them like it was
just a joke in it it was just a joke but
they did call me on Tuesday nights yeah
and it would if it was like 15 bucks you
got a steak really I see a comedian
[ __ ] great they will eat during will
hours I'm saying yeah so hours to house
and see but to become the emcee I had to
win a contest the first time and you had
to qualify so the first time I went up I
want unskilled believe it or not I
stayed up late to eat right those
[ __ ] stupid jokes of mine Godzilla
God knows what else in the second time I
just brought all of people I worked with
out of office so just those 13 people
laughing made me win that category so I
figured it out so when I went to the
quarterfinals
I didn't go deep deep deep into the back
of that and a couple picking those days
aces so value yeah I was getting value
from this [ __ ] hell billion and one
poor bastard the last time I got him was
like ten thousand valium I said I'll be
back on now he didn't see me for like a
year
what happened to you man I was waiting
for you lost your address
I laugh before cellphones how do you
even carry 10,000 the only 800 bottles
what you talking he would show up this
crazy [ __ ] what's show up you don't like
when you go to work with your kids don't
gummy best dog yeah you ripped the bag
yeah yeah he would have one of those
bags double with a seal and there were
10 milligram valium at the Alma 1e game
3 for $0.50 and I [ __ ] took him in
New York there were three [ __ ] dollars
aside just took him to New York me I had
those things for months oh so people
like those things yeah it's like those
yeah see so both coke and Valium so I
would tell people here's the deal you
want to buy coke yeah all right come to
Atlanta o'clock come on man I don't want
to pay for comedy show I wasn't fight
throwing around throwing poo
alright you got it so I'd make him sit
out so the night of the championship I
had 100 people that yeah and I wouldn't
give him the coke laughter I go out of
state sad cuz it's not they leave oh
yeah even that yeah that's how I want
coke cans yeah they're not gonna sit
around oh my god I would torment them to
death I'd tell them yeah it's in my
pocket I can't reach the camera come on
man give me this [ __ ] [ __ ] you because I
started in Chicago and the open mics
they were good cuz they were regular
audiences then when I went to New York I
was like this is a washing is it because
my parents were lit they were living
there at the time okay cuz we're Chicago
in Philadelphia my parents are from
Chicago say what they would my dad law
my dad
switch job so they were in Chicago so I
moved out there I dropped out of college
but anyway so I was I was doing shows
there and I was like oh I'm pretty good
so then I moved to New York and I was
like holy [ __ ] I couldn't get a [ __ ]
laugh because I was I was performing for
all comics you know and they don't
[ __ ] laugh and that God and then
Ichiro floor and then you want it then
you want to [ __ ] kill yourself cuz
you don't even know what to do you can't
get you can't get your hands on a
regular audience you know that's what
it's like out here open mics out here
yeah they're the same way oh god I was
like I really I was like I really [ __ ]
up I should have never left Chicago I
should have stayed but then if you stay
somewhere too long you get comfortable
an onion
[ __ ] me and you end up marrying a
[ __ ] fat lady and then you know
whatever and you want you like I should
have left I should have moved to New
York or LA or whatever but that's
whatever I'm not against fat people by
the way I'm just saying I was happy you
came on camera you're a crazy
[ __ ] and you mean it and that's
why I like my tank kids Irish Catholic
you got all the makings to be a [ __ ]
psycho you could have been stabbed
people so look yeah I can I kept it
under control
my wife is Hispanic you know so she she
she understands like she doesn't mind my
personality defects
you know Rico and she's Panamanian oh
yes very crazy she don't mind like I I'm
always like oh yeah they used to like
why the [ __ ] does she like just not pack
up and go so you don't have any money
but other than that like why did you
just [ __ ] pack up and go like I don't
get it cuz I would if I I could well I
believe myself I don't know what's gonna
do a problem I'm a she threatens to but
it's like I'm just amazed cuz I'm not
I'm not I think you know being from a
big family [ __ ] you up and I'm doing it
being show business [ __ ] you up so I
tried it like you know I try to like be
a good dad but I'm not a good husband
you know but she like tolerates it you
know I don't [ __ ] cheat on her
nothing but like I should be more
nurturing and I got on take her where
she always wants me to take around and
I'm like I go out I go out to the clubs
I want to [ __ ] out on my day off I don't
want to [ __ ] go out and sit there in
[ __ ] you go out to dinner and look at
you I want to be real more since 2000
like five or some [ __ ] but you know
women want to go out all day yeah but
she I think but I don't want to take her
to a club cuz that's my [ __ ] job you
know so I always feel bad I can't take
her out but like I tried to and then I
always fail you know I just don't want
to go out I don't like going out
sedative written in New York you go to
you eight you go out to eat there's like
there's like a [ __ ] dude right next
to you you don't get up you don't get
any you don't get any space so it's
annoying you're mad I mean I'm not I
don't know
I try yeah and then what do you wear you
go out to a nice restaurant yeah get a
nice bottle of wine
no nobody drinks here no no you just do
you just whatever you do with your don't
[ __ ] yeah so I should do that but
hopefully there's a TV at the [ __ ]
ball we sing and watch the game
yeah cuz I don't know the thing that's
when you're married long and long enough
there's really I mean it's like you you
don't you just run out of things to talk
about you know and I sure I shouldn't
have in podcast you know my wife will go
how is the podcast and then I'll talk
about that sugar how is the show and
I'll talk about that so I'm like not a
good husband like I almost don't give a
[ __ ] about like I should give like she's
like you never ask me about me I'm like
how's it goin but I don't even get I bet
you know I hate to do it I skate but I
barely apparently like I'm trying I'm
trying to be a better husband have you
considered counselling know how we went
I can't now I know man I know what
they're gonna say well they gonna say
they're gonna say just take her out
we'll take the round I know I'm gonna
when we go back but we've been going
we've been going out to the [ __ ] this
is like a big vacation where oh well you
know she's in the beach he's at this in
the Sun all day because she said she if
she doesn't get Sun she gets depressed
yeah she's Panama so she'd the winter
was too long just this winter and so
she's like so she seemed happy today but
when I left she seemed like she was a
little like in a good mood coastal
waterways of a crab that's really what
it is yeah if she gives their Santa now
good Chinese food if really I heard a
sigh for all with Chinese people charge
are the pan I mean is they don't make
their own food they're not known for
that right no no they have a market like
a ceviche market that is [ __ ] for
naught and you went there as a comic or
you went there just let me in the
country I got follow these how do you
know where they've good Chinese food
because I know that's because my best
friend is [ __ ] don't make me call this
[ __ ] now my best friend my brother is
for [ __ ]
there but it's true that because my wife
says they got so they got a lot of rich
Chinese people there a lot of rich Asian
people there they buy all the condos and
they they probably want a good [ __ ]
Chinese meal yeah I said they got
tremendous Chinese from Kevin Brennan
we're done
can I get my Twitter Kevin Burt yeah
give them whatever you guys haven't
Brandon 666 and the instant on the
Instagram and Twitter Facebook I got a
666 what's the problem no I just had
children
no I Kevin I know Kevin Brennan was
taking I'm like slow to all this because
I was done when I was in 2008 I quit I
basically quit it's 2007 2000 I was like
I'm done
but 666 was available yeah 666 was
available Kevin Brennan and then so I
just took it as a joke and then but now
my podcast is like I'm you know that
people think it's like part of the whole
branding where I'm like I'm crazy I talk
a lot of crazy [ __ ] and like I got into
a lot of fights out of respect for you
I'm not was not I was not too combative
I don't want to interrupt the church no
no we love you so so we're in the area
it'll be a pleasure Kevin Brennan 666 on
Instagram and Twitter and I would like
to build up my Twitter a little bit I
was when I first started doing it like
Opie and Norton stop my Twitter was like
a 500 now it's like at 15,000 so it'd be
nice to get up to 30,000 and sure and
just like that yeah I don't know yeah
don't have to buy people have to buy
[ __ ] Asian BOTS no I'll do it
no you gotta [ __ ] go on Twitter and
talk to people and tell me I dare lakyn
and then I get suspended when I get when
I open up I get suspended anyways a
pleasure thank you for having me thank
you thanks shout out to shout to Esther
ku and Teamster Tammy for helping
consolidate this uh this happening
disarrangement up teams to Timmy he's a
good people he's solid his brothers
[ __ ] solid I grew up in that house
Timmy H running Secaucus anyway thank
you Kevin so far [ __ ] hopefully
next week the bronchi this will be good
I got prescriptions
I gotta empty my Alex I do I'm not the
ceiling
he doesn't want to [ __ ] the genero them
are you having a reaction today
antibiotics I'm having a reaction
everything it's a reaction to
cheeseburgers Gianna's yes please
that was whatever we would came in here
two days ago
I'm sick of the dog he gives me two
different kinds animals like the fact
that I didn't take a blonde hand I'm
surprised he didn't throw the pong that
might hit the other balls work there now
do whatever they do they do work the CBD
stop talking coughing I offered it that
mean you don't think the CD stops you
from coughing he's a half a [ __ ] he keeps
it in those discount cough drops with
CVS yeah I use them I go for the
discount you gotta go for the VIX the
full-blast food no that no they're too
strong for those things they have my on
this sugar pills not that gooey Center
how many [ __ ] calories of these I
don't know how many kept you don't look
at calories for cough drops you know you
just eat away Haiti to know I mean I
know I don't need to think I don't need
to [ __ ] things of these I know they
rot your teeth I go for the sugarless
ones I had to sound like a half a [ __ ] by
kuznick sugarless coffee ops CBS brand
too and I and I like ranch dressing
what's a while eat some hummus though
this I only waited something on the show
you tell you so you don't kick me out no
no no I I want you don't bring it around
me and I'll never see you doing it why
are you doing it in public then you
gotta you gotta like taking a glove just
smacking me in the face I'd rather you
do that huh bolita ranch dressing
also like I said in the beginning if you
a-five a-six of your fat [ __ ] like uncle
Joey you looking for Agee Fuji sport
calm slash church like I said whether
it's the [ __ ] purple one whether it's
the
Seiko whether it's a super Otto or
whether it's the element all those guys
I got in there [ __ ] tremendous I'm a
big guy people tugging on me in the
closed guard talking about me talk about
me know
and no rips no nothing I had a gear I
got before from pro some guy went to
[ __ ] pull me over and he ripped my
[ __ ] G Fuji you could [ __ ] pull
that thing solid and if you're a big guy
you feel comfortable go to Fuji
sports.com right now I'm pressing charge
BAM hit 10% off the Liberty and
[ __ ] house alright and that's
it and that's that I love you guys I'll
see you Sunday
tip top Magoo ready to go next Thursday
it's all that's left in Columbus ok you
[ __ ] together
Columbus funny bone will be doing
[ __ ] but I Bing the whole [ __ ]
thing we're doing everything next week
and if we don't get healed then they
can't come to Columbus because we're
giving them to cushy bears a day for
4/20 you're going to Columbus tale I did
that guy think it depends on if I'm
doing better but to push you punch for
breakfast will do what do they have for
breakfast in Columbus can I get
something good no he'll take me
somewhere keep me like you got order the
salad and no diet coke and no bread and
you give me those edibles and you're
trying to make me good but then then at
the end of the meal or a milkshake
and say I have to order a milkshake
that's the one time we win we got high
time I remember I like them because I
team is you will go to this pumpkin
Denny's and get shot I'm saying this
[ __ ] yeah this place in Lancashire you
got to be shaky over that yeah people
missing
anyway Fuji sports calm get 10% off
again I want to give Kevin Brendan thank
you - flying Jew and you people for
supporting us stay black and my girl
keeps you sitting there throwing heat as
usual stay black have a great weekend
love you kick that mule Lee